تخيل عالمًا حيث يمكن لأجهزة الكمبيوتر التحدث
إلينا مثل أصدقائنا المقربين ، ولكن
بذكاء عالم الصواريخ ،
استعد للضحك ، وربما حتى ترمي
جهاز الكمبيوتر الخاص بك إلى النافذة لأن
أحدث تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي ، gbt هنا
لتغيير الأمور ومثل
محادثة Fairy Godmother الشريرة تمتلك GPT
القدرة على تحويل حياتك الدنيوية الرهيبة
إلى أرض عجائب تكنولوجية أو
قلبها رأسًا على عقب وتركك عاطلًا عن العمل.  التي
فتنت الإنترنت
بقدرتها المذهلة على إنشاء نص من
الدعائم ، كيف ترى الآن كيف
يمكن أن يؤثر برنامج الدردشة المذهل هذا على
مهن الأشخاص وكيف يمكن أن يؤثر
على وظائف الأشخاص في غضون بضع سنوات
بشكل جيد إذا كان لدينا يوم يمكنني ملء  كل
ساعة في ذلك اليوم مع بعض
مخاطر هذه التكنولوجيا ولماذا يجب أن
نكون مفتونين ومهتمين ، لكن
دعني أقدم أولاً وقبل كل شيء هذا
النظام لأنني  في الحقيقة أن أنظمتنا العديدة
خاطئة تمامًا ،
فبعض برامج الذكاء الاصطناعي الأكثر
تقدمًا مقنعة لنا وهي تقدم
معلومات خاطئة أو معلومات
غير كاملة أو خاطئة تمامًا ليس
بالضرورة بغرض
خداعنا ولكن لأنك تعلم أن هذه الأنظمة
لا تزال قائمة  جديد نوعًا ما
الآن قد يؤدي هذا إلى سيناريو كابوس
حيث يمكننا تخيله
استنادًا إلى أحداث الأخبار العاجلة
أو القصص السريعة التي يتم إنشاؤها أو الأشخاص الذين
يحاولون عن قصد تضليل
الآخرين لتوليد معلومات أو محتوى مقنع بشكل لا يصدق
ومضلل للغاية
والذي تعرف أنه يمكن أن
يتسبب بسرعة  الاضطرابات بطرق أعتقد أنه
بالنظر إلى ما مررنا به على مدار
العامين الماضيين ، لا أحد يريده
بعد الآن ،
لذلك هناك تحدٍ كامل للمعلومات الخاطئة
أمامنا في الأفق ، أما
الآخر
فيتعلق باقتصادنا ، وأرى
أن هذا يُستخدم باعتباره  نوع من
التشغيل الآلي الأسرع أو الأتمتة الأسرع لأنواع معينة من
وظائف ذوي الياقات البيضاء في الشركات
أنت  تعرف على أحد الأشياء المثيرة للاهتمام
حول دردشة GPT هو أنها تتذكر أن
لديها القدرة على تذكر ما
تحدثت عنه في الماضي مما يعني أنها
تقدم تخصيصًا عميقًا الآن
من ناحية ، إنه أمر رائع للشركات التي
أعتقد أن هذا يحدث ثورة في
مراكز الاتصال و  خدمة العملاء إذا كان
لديها القدرة على تذكر كل
عميل على حدة يفهم عواطفه في
تلك اللحظة ومن ثم إنشاء
نص برمجي على الفور للحصول على هذا العميل
ما يحتاجه للشعور بالرضا دون
التضحية بأي شيء ماليًا
للشركة
ولكن هذا يشير أيضًا إليك  تعرف على
تغيير سريع للأحداث لأولئك الذين يعملون
في خدمة العملاء ، من الصعب
تخيل مستقبل حيث
ستكون هناك حاجة إلى عمال خدمة عملاء بشريين في المستقبل